nadia et vous êtes député de la 11e
circonscription d évident racontez nous
un peu pour vous en tant que politique
en tant qu'élu comment vous vivez ce
confinement
et bien nous le vivons comme les réseaux
rites et de l'eau de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui qui sont confinés chez eux
c'est à dire que nous sommes confinés
avec notre famille pour ceux qui ont des
enfants avec un suivi scolaire qui est
mis en place pour les enfants et avec
une activité tout de même professionnel
qui continue donc pour le en télétravail
évidemment et donc l'attractivité de
parlementaires continuent même confiné
chez nous oui justement on le sait le
travail de parlementaire c'est un
travail avec beaucoup de tâches un
emploi du temps rempli d'habitude
comment vous vous travailler
concrètement vous le disiez télétravail
mais ça passe aussi par watt s'appelait
messagerie facebook twitter j'imagine
que il ya tout un arsenal qui est
développé pour pouvoir continuer à faire
son travail d'élu
oui bien sûr on a tous les dispositifs
et des réseaux à notre disposition
travail par mail beaucoup on travaille
sur nos boucles de de discussion sur des
boucles télégramme sur des boucles wazza
et un communiqué on se tient aussi
informé par les réseaux twitter ou
facebook donc effective est
effectivement se sert aujourd'hui de
tous les appareils réseaux sociaux qui
sont à disposition pour pouvoir
communauté aujourd'hui avait des député
des yvelines qui était à l'assemblée
nationale est aussi en commission pour
poursuivre le travail trois seulement
par groupe parlementaire ce que vous
avez regardé un peu ces débats est ce
que c'est un peu frustrant aussi de ne
pas y est de pas pouvoir faire
pleinement son travail évidemment que
c'est frustrant puisque nous avons envie
de participer au débat nous avons des
choses à dire à l'instant t mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que je suis
commissaire vos finances
donc normalement s'il n'y avait pas ces
pertes de confinement j'aurais été dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui mais nous avons
préparé en amont avec les commissaires
aux finances qui siège aujourd'hui avec
le rapporteur général du budget la
discussion qui se tient en ce moment
même pour porter justement la voix de la
majorité
parlementaire pour pouvoir s'exprimer
sur ce texte qui est aujourd'hui
essentiel pour nos concitoyens
alors on ne peut pas y être touche il a
fallu faire un choix le choix qui a été
fait c'était de nommer les deux
vice-présidents de notre commission des
finances pour ce qui est du groupe de la
république en marche et le rapporteur
général du budget